- ♪ Yeah, I'm talkin' to you ♪
♪ Don't just sit there
feeling blue ♪
♪ When you feel
there's nothing you can do ♪
♪ You just pick yourself
right off the ground ♪
♪ Get on up and turn around ♪
♪ Hey, hey ♪
[elegant piano music playing]
- Felipe, where are they?
- Right over there.
- I mean, what could I do?
I pay for the coffee.
I pick up the dog,
and I tell the cop
that I'm with animal control,
undercover.
I still have the dog.
[laughter]
- A million dollars?
Heck yeah, we got a deal.
Carter?
Carter Grant,
VP of marketing, Chrysler?
- Uh, yeah.
Have we met?
- We're about to.
Sam Duvet.
- Uh, hi, Sam.
- Tim Cramblin,
Cramblin Advertising.
- Hello, Tim.
- Cramblin Advertising?
Are you Hank Cramblin's son?
- That I am, yeah.
- Oh.
- You know
Sally Pomerantz?
Head of creative
for Pomerantz and Klein.
- Hank Cramblin,
what a legend.
How is your father?
- He went insane.
He lives in a nuthouse now.
- Oh.
Well, the next time
you see him,
you tell him Sally Pomerantz
from Chicago said hello.
- He won't understand that.
Talking to him is like
talking to Bugs Bunny.
- Well, then you tell him,
"What's up, Doc?"
- Thank you.
That'll mean a lot to him.
- Sally Pomerantz.
Just as lovely
as I'd always imagined.
I mean,
wrong color but...
just as lovely.
- Yeah, he imagines
everyone black.
- I suppose it's because
I'm black.
- Oh, that could be.
- Could be.
- That could...
- Could...
both: Be.
- Carter, we are
on our way out
because we already
ate here.
Look at these stains
on our ties.
- Look at the receipt.
- I'm guessing
all the agencies are in town
because you're hearing pitches
for your new campaign.
Well, Cramblin would love
to throw our hat in the ring
on that.
- Oh.
Well, have I seen your work?
- Oh, you sure have.
Delta Airlines,
Budweiser--
- No, no, no.
Not your father's.
Yours.
- Oh, uh...
- How about Smith's
baby and teen kid furniture?
Harry Dean, the DUI lawyer?
Frank Franklin Insurance?
- Oh, I've seen that one.
♪ 313-555-0197 ♪
Frank Franklin.
- That's so us.
- That's us!
- No, it's, uh--
that's a very catchy tune,
yeah.
But, you know, I'm just not sure
that your firm
is what we're looking for
right now, gentlemen.
- Oh, sure, 'cause you're
probably gonna go
with these fine folks
from Chicago
'cause that's where
you make your cars.
Wait a minute.
No, you don't.
Where do they make
their cars, Sam?
- Right here in Detroit.
- Come on, Carter.
- You make your cars here.
Make your ads here.
- [chuckles softly]
Fellas, it took a lot of balls
coming in here like this.
- Well, we were already
eating here, so...
- Receipt, so...
- Right, the receipt, yeah.
Um...
tell you what.
Why don't you come by
tomorrow?
Hmm? 8:00.
- 8:00? I can't at 8:00.
I just can't.
I have dinner with my wife,
and I can't cancel.
- Oh, no, I meant a.m.
- a.m., yeah.
Makes way more sense.
- Yeah.
- A little early.
- We'll be there, okay?
See you in the morning.
Thank you.
- Okay.
- Gentlemen.
Mrs. Pomerantz.
- Ms.
- Oh.